when we talk about being prepared the
area we are at least prepared with is
taking care of people at the earliest
stages of their illness because the
large number of people won't come in
because they either uninsured or
underinsured and people tend not to
think of health care the health care
system as an element of this problem and
being prepared but the speed with which
we recognize new cases in any outbreak
not just influenza but an anthrax attack
bioterrorism event SARS is extremely
important in control measures and the
longer you get significant pockets of
population not coming for care when they
become ill is a serious problem for
these type of pandemics